well we're going to go back now to
Thailand and get an update on the
shooting that's happened at a daycare
center in the country our Asia
correspondent Cordelia Lynch is on the
line now Cody what more can you tell us
well incredibly distressing news coming
out of Thailand today 34 people police
say have been killed including 22
children in a mass shooting at a
preschool in a North Eastern province of
Thailand the attacker a former policeman
we're told also killed his wife and
child before shooting himself dead local
officials say about 30 children were at
the center when the gunman entered the
building at about 12 30 it was during
the children's nap time particularly
Grim detail to this story that is
unfolding as we speak a district
official has had that the attack at
first shot four or five members of Staff
including a teacher who was eight months
pregnant
describes people thinking initially that
it was fireworks that were going off and
there are some very distressing videos
and images on social media showing doing
sheets covering what appears to be the
bodies of children lying in pools of
blood at this Center it is in the town
of utai
in the North Eastern province of non
guadalampu and local police have
provided quite a lot of
information and context
in the hours that have followed this
attack they say he was armed with a
shotgun a pistol and a knife and that he
fled the scene in a vehicle local media
have said he fled and then returned to
his own home and that is where he killed
his own wife and child we're also told
by the superintendent of the local
police station that the government was
discharged from the police force last
year now gun ownership in Thailand is
high compared with other countries in
the region but official figures don't
include illegal weapons that have kind
of crossed a very porous border there
but mass shootings in Thailand
relatively rare the the last significant
one I've noticed in 2020
um but this is something that the nation
will be reeling from and as I say
incredibly distressing details